judd apatow is walking in the room thank
god yes this is it this this is it
crowded it goes over you that's left
there I know it's it we're slowly
difference just falling off one by one
by one so Sam shadow what happens what
happened what happened while I was gone
I know no question we were actually just
talking about that but a lot of the a
lot of the other hosts on the channel I
guess everything's an uproar now and
people are insecure and there are people
who are legitimately I believe thinks
that I'm some kind of a evil
manipulative mastermind who has designed
this all to eventually just become the
Sam channel you know this is how it
happens it's how the world works as much
as there's a guy and you don't think
he's the guy and then you realize wait a
second the last man standing right Sam
and Donald Trump
that's it means the two of us and we've
somehow taken control and everybody else
you're right they don't see it coming ah
he'll never win I don't even have to
vote who's gonna do that exactly what
the guy from The Apprentice is gonna be
the president right Sam is going to get
his own channel never gonna happen
what I find most hilarious is this week
Clay Aiken said that when he was on The
Apprentice it was very clear that Donald
Trump did not get to choose what who won
Clay Aiken is now turned on Donald PS
Clay Aiken and that I find hilarious
because we all think well clearly he's
capable of being the president he was
able to choose the winners on The
Apprentice
he doesn't even have the freaking
ability to choose on his own who wins
each episode of The Apprentice so you
think the producers are like now we
can't let this maniac decide to the
apprentices well exactly because on all
those shows those always like one
lunatic and you would you would kick off
that lunatic week one right and that
person always gets kicked off like week
nine right because the producers like
you can kick off that psycho they're the
most fun to watch like Gary Busey has to
stay yes exactly and that's why it's so
funny that he was not even given that
responsibility and I agree with that I
agree that the amount of responsibility
Donald Trump should have should be less
then the ability to choose the winner
each week on the apprentice you should
have less responsibility than that we
shouldn't trust them even with that
although I think it was oh you're not a
are you not a trump guy well you know
I'm beginning to wonder if I made a
mistake yeah I
we had Penn Jillette in here wild-ass
and he was talking about the apprentice
he warned everybody Penn he said that
like I'm the apprentice though whether
Donna he didn't say the Donald Trump can
get to pick him but he did say that
sometimes those boardroom meetings he
would go like four hours yes everything
in TV goes for hours and but it wouldn't
be like to set up shots it would be
Donald just talking and talking oh come
on imagine that's why none of those
dailies come out yeah get the fact that
some people claim he says racist things
or I'm sure he's talking about women or
whatever let's assume that's possible I
don't know but I think we wouldn't elect
him president if we just heard him
babbling like a madman just if we do
what he actually cared to talk about we
wouldn't want to be the president just
him talking about his lunch and what he
watched on TV would probably have
prevented this from happening there's
this great moment I watched The
Apprentice religious I did too I would
say big fan but I didn't watch it
because I respected the bad I wash it
cuz he was a lunatic yeah I watched it
because I found it so funny that he
didn't do anything and he would just
send his kids out and then he would make
an impulsive decision which seems to be
wrong right and mean yeah or or sexist
and crazy I always remember when he had
keshia knight pulliam
from that Cosby Show you remember she
had yeah didn't last long did she what
happened was that people were raising
money for charity and cause and and
Trump kept going why didn't you call
Bill Cosby and ask him for money why
didn't you call Bill Cosby and she's
like I don't kind of a kind of
relationship with him and at the time we
didn't know right we were just beginning
to find out I think we thought this had
been taped before the cosmic scandal
broke but was airing after right I think
that's right and it was so clear that
she was terrified of Cosby and who knows
why who knows what the levels of it are
who
what she understands or doesn't
understand but regardless really
terrified Cosby to the point of her eyes
welled up with tears and you could tell
that Trump on some level knew he knew
that this was her wound
whatever that wound was and he kept
going like but why didn't you call Cosby
you should have called Cosby if you
wanted to make more money and and so he
got her her it's a break right broke on
TV which is egg you he knows good TV he
knows how to make television he knows
how to make moments by being
confrontational I mean he's a strange
man who knows that if you just stir some
[ __ ] up people like to watch that more
than boring stuff right it's it's hard
to say if it's great television he's
like you know he's a easily watched it
if he wasn't the president he's a funny
guy to observe if he didn't ruin your
life and take away your health insurance
I don't know if you remember when he did
this but I always remember him doing
this and it's just now that he's
president I get reminded of it all the
time in my head you could tell it was a
line that he loved and so he needed to
leave it left in the show because it had
nothing to do with the episode but you
remember the episodes would be set up
where he would meet the contestants
outside to explain what their task would
be so this one episode it's in New York
and they're on the roof and it's the
winter and no it's not the winter
actually it's like April and he looks at
everybody he goes hey how many of us are
cold today and like some of them raised
their hand and then he just like leans
in he goes so why does everybody keep
saying global warming is a thing oh my
god let her all you dear friends yes it
is
not it not tight it was part of the
episode he's so bad that he has a
ventilation in his buildings it's so
expensive that's a proper ventilation
that he doesn't he doesn't want to
believe in global warming I want to say
one thing before I forget I got to be at
the Wilbur in Boston on July 24 Wow and
I'm doing two shows here the second
shows for charity it's for after-school
arts programs for high schools July 24
in the first show is for you go to Judd
Apatow calm for tickets second show is
for charity
on Boston it's for after-school programs
we need children to learn things about
art so that they are kind compassionate
people right you can draw who can draw
who can think yes creative people are
kind people
so yeah Judd Apatow Khammam at the
Wilbur and the 24th I'm going to be in
Rhode Island that week as well you're a
gig in comic I'm a gig in comic and then
the big sick comes out nationwide today
so let me ask you as your as your
promoting this stuff because I want to
talk to you a lot about your your comedy
and everything that because I just think
it's amazing what it's turned into but
when you're talking about Trump as much
as you are on Twitter and inevitably it
comes up in interviews and stuff like
that and you take this very very very
clear stance and to the point where it's
not even like well if you ask me about
it I'll tell you like there you are
you're in airily vocal to the point
where like you know you can look at I'm
sure any show you go on a bunch of the
listeners like well [ __ ] that guy even
though everything you've ever done they
may be a fan of does that do you ever go
like maybe I know I don't because
there's a moment in life yeah when we're
supposed to say no but I said what are
we going to do I mean maybe if I
couldn't pay my rent I would I would be
scared but not even like that hey my
rents am not even pay my rent so what
what am I going to do it's funny because
we're always you know learning about
history and we go why didn't somebody do
something yeah why did somebody say
something and we're clearly in a
situation with a corrupt president who's
not very smart who his interests are
confused that has nothing to do with
whether or not you're a Republican or a
Democrat you could be a Republican I
think the world would work better with
less government and lower taxes and
maybe you're against abortion I I
respect people who have those opinions
whether I agree with them or not I think
that this man is not capable of doing
the job right and I don't trust him
I think he is a liar we know he's a liar
I think that we should all be very
concerned with how his brain works and
it's very scary and I
that he shouldn't be the president it's
as simple as that but however not even
if not even about money because of
course you can pay your rent but well
that's a driver for people speaking up
because uh because yeah there are people
just like love and I'm not going to your
movie right well I don't know I I'm not
at the point where that might my terror
about that is the driver yeah you know I
care about people I love everybody I
want everyone to be happy I want people
to live in a safe world I would like it
that if people are sick they can pay to
go to the doctor my mom had ovarian
cancer I remember her going through
those insurance forms wondering if this
new experimental treatment which might
save her life would be covered right
there's nothing worse in the world and
so you know when you have somebody who
puts that at risk
for tens of millions of people we all
have to go hey hey slow down you're
right but on a not as big level on a
smaller level that's just for you like
because Camille you know obviously that
start and just writer and everything
with the big sick is also outwardly
political about his opinions I if I was
creating something a part of me would
want to know that I could count on an
audience to go in unbiased like I just
want to know what you think of this
movie and a lot of what's going on is
not allowing people everybody's got an
opinion you know yeah John Lennon wasn't
Pro Nixon tell me was not and he wasn't
sitting around going I'm not going to
speak out against the Vietnam War
because I need to sell more units and
imagine it didn't happen this is what we
all needs we're all citizens right we're
allowed to have our opinions and we're
allowed to share them and there are
people I don't agree with and I still
can enjoy what they do creatively as
long as they're not a lunatic right I
mean I can't say I'm running to James
Woods movie but to be fair I know if you
would have been doing that
well I love The Onion field but I feel
like some of what he does is
intentionally hurtful right I'm sure he
doesn't perceive it that way I think I
think there's a certain amount of
insensitivity that people express
because they're passionate and I
understand it we're all scared and so we
could all cross the line then I find an
understandable but I do think people
need to speak up and if people really
believe in getting rid of health
insurance for billions of people I think
they should speak up also in a healthy
way that's what our democracy is based
on yes so we're all supposed to have our
opinions and we're allowed to share them
as long as we don't hurt each other and
as long as people forget that though
these days people don't don't feel like
on either side that the opposing person
should have equal footing in terms of
speaking I have no issue with anyone
saying anything as long as they don't
threaten people yeah I just don't like
being lied to
from either side I just I don't like
when people say I never met with the
Russians and suddenly there's tons of
meetings I don't like that I don't like
the vet Jeff sessions of that or Kushner
or Don Trump jr. or whoever else did it
I feel like that's my concern I totally
respect you if you think the economy
will work better if I have lower taxes I
may not agree with that as an approach
but that's great but I don't want you to
[ __ ] me
and I don't like just the tearing down
of all of Obama's policies just because
they were Obama's that in spite instead
of actually figuring out what we're
doing here no they said the other day in
the news that Donald Trump didn't want
to do a bunch of things with Isis
because that was the Obama approach but
Obama had great generals in well you
know a lot of the same people that Trump
works with and there's only so many ways
to go at these things so when you're
trying to get rid of things just to just
to prove your difference yeah that I
find to be very scary and I don't trust
corporations
I mean corporations want to make more
money and if they can make more money
polluting a stream they will do it yes
and that's what people don't understand
that's what regulation
are about I'm sure we don't need
ridiculous regulations but just know
companies will [ __ ] you over for cash
because companies aren't people it's
just their large groups of people
something we've learned in Hollywood of
course you have learned this you know
this is why you you'll get certain
product because people are looking for
money and this whole idea of like let
the rich people be richer and we'll take
care of you yeah give me all the money
and I might give you a little bit like I
don't believe in that that general
theory that you know Exxon will hook us
up these companies will pretend there's
no global warming they'll do anything
that doesn't cost them more money even
if it kills you and it's funny that
Trump found a way to say I'm not the
elite he's the definition of the elite
but he doesn't speak like the elite yeah
but that is anybody who doesn't wanna
read a book oh so yeah I'm like one of
you it's a it's a ridiculous point of
view and I'm worried that people did
manipulate it into believing and I hope
people don't don't get hurt before this
is over in the sense that you have a man
making a lot of decisions that I that
affects people it dis insurance thing
you know I don't you know I'm sure
there's a lot of people out there that
who have had that moment where they say
I can't go to that doctor in that day
because my insurance doesn't cover it
but what about all the other people that
say that Obamacare was a lie and the
premiums have gone up and they can only
pick one provider and I think that's a
lot of that is very valid I think that
there's problems but we all have to
remember that Mitch McConnell said it
publicly I'm my strategy is to make sure
that Obama gets nothing accomplished
right so what should have happened is
Obamacare was passed and then we should
have spent the next six years
fine-tuning it working on and so when
you have you know the Republicans saying
we're not going to fix anything they
want it to not work because that gets
them elected that's evil that is truly
evil and I do think people were misled
in some aspects about Obamacare and and
that's how they got it passed I I think
it was terrible that they did that but
this is what we have and we should fix
it and tearing it down just so open
never existed it just it's just going to
hurt a lot of people when did are you
surprised at what politics has done to
some of some comedians like for instance
I think Amy Schumer has been affected a
lot because of the political climate you
know I mean I remember any Schumer kind
of being universally beloved and then
seemingly I don't know where there was
this huge backlash against I think that
has a little bit more to do with women
is that there's a lot of insecure men
that have trouble with brilliant strong
women and so you see that sometimes when
people like Amy or Lena Dunham yeah Lena
Dunham the same way makeup but our
political but what are they fighting for
really well I mean they're fighting for
women to be equal that bothers you it
bothers you that they think we should
have same gun laws did you have any idea
when you were getting into this when you
were when you were starting like
projects with Amy and Lena and like just
finding funny women or men and putting
them on putting getting their projects
made that it would become kind of the
political war it has I didn't but the
whole country's become that yeah I'm
proud of them I think they're amazing if
anybody out there knew them they would
they would be their best friends they
would love them they're so smart and so
funny and it takes balls to stand up and
say I believe in this and you'd have to
agree with that yeah but it takes a lot
of courage and you put a lot of things
at risk when you when you fight for
things and and what are they fighting
for they actually are fighting for you
and so some people don't like that but I
also think it has to do with people
being insecure I think that people get
insecure about strong women and I think
you could write college papers about the
psychological issues that would make
anyone have an issue with them because
they couldn't be funnier or cooler and
their positions are just very you know
simple and insane yeah I mean that's
true you talk to guys all the time they
never want to date a woman that's
funnier than them because that's the
thing right that's the one thing that
you have a good eye I get it right I
I've made the mistake of a married woman
who's way funnier uh sometimes we both
do talk shows and I like it it will be
promoting something and I'm on Fallon
and she's on kobir and she's so much
better than me she
so which word charisma she's faster and
it hurts I'm not going to say it doesn't
hurt right so you watch act only I had a
when did you when was the the point that
you found we found your love for stand
up or got back into it as a real thing I
in my head I feel like it was when you
were doing funny people and and that
kind of seemed like it got the the
sparks going I think so I had to do a
little stand up to write jokes for Adam
and Seth so I got on stage not too many
times maybe a dozen times just to figure
out what they would say and I did a show
at Just for Laughs in Montreal called
Apatow for Destruction where I had all
the people who do stand-up or in my
movies on the show so it was Seth and
Ken Jong and Craig Robinson and Russell
Brand and Charlyne Yi and it was so much
fun and I think it really did my
interest in doing stand-up speaking of
which I'm at Just for Laughs this year I
love you and I am doing five shows there
for which I'm taping for Netflix Wow so
you can go to Apatow com Judd Apatow
come and come see me so you getting an
application special yes well it goes my
turn oh yeah I'm also we're mostly going
to be just I could tell you guys I mean
I'm in Rhode Island an amazing
Providence Columbus theatre July 25th if
you want to see me if you're in Rhode
Island and something like it is it a
romantic thing to be able because you
don't have to perform stand-up you can
live your life in the big studios of
Hollywood now I could hide in my house
yeah I don't know anything really
enormous hedges yes do you like the idea
of like like getting down back to the
base level of show business where's you
and a microphone and your audience and
that's it's just purified that's all I
ever wanted to do everything else has
been just a terrible distraction when I
first started all I wanted to be was a
comedian I started doing stand-up when I
was 17 at East Side comedy club on Long
Island I said work at governor's on Long
Island and then I went to college at USC
and started doing stand-up out in LA and
I did it for seven years I probably
burnt myself out I was so obsessed I
just kept getting better
writing work and it paid so much better
and I was hungry I couldn't afford to
live on my stand-up money and then I
created the Ben Stiller show with Ben I
was going to ask what the project was
that that removed you have told me out
of again it was you know it was 20 hours
a day for a year and there was no time
to go to a comedy club and then when the
show was over I got offered a job
working at the Larry Sanders Show and at
The Critic the Jon Lovitz Adam already
and then I was just tired and then I
thought maybe the universe doesn't want
me to do it yeah and and then when I was
working with Amy Schumer I'm trainwreck
she just seemed to be having so much fun
I came to see her at the Comedy Cellar
and I thought why am I alone in a room
all the time and this seems like so much
more fun and I think it's a way to stay
connected to people it's very easy to
lose your way and get all crusty and
unfunny and totally and when you talk
directly to people every night when you
talk to people every night you get a
sense of what people are thinking about
what they find funny and I think it's
helped my writing on on girls and love
and crashing just that I'm more
connected to people well at what point
was heavy weights heavy weights I love
heavy weights but what point was in that
thing with heavy weights we did heavy
weights I ground 94 when I was writing
at the Larry Sanders Show and I wrote it
with a Steve Brill who directed it and
you know looking back it was just so
much fun we took over a summer camp for
a few months Kenan Thompson was one of
the yeah of course and we knew it at the
time we were like disk it's insanely
funny
I have such memories of going to a
minor-league baseball game or like the
Braves the minor-league Braves team with
Kenan and just thinkin this is the
funniest kid I've ever seen really and
Shawn Weiss is so funny and um Aaron and
and Feig was in that movie puffy of
course he played the skin counselor who
I used to be fat and still it was the
bad guy I guess before something about
Mary or any of that stuff
he's brilliant I mean honestly it's
pretty clear starch ball and hair like
that's Tony Perkis yes he's doing a
variation I think
the same logo yeah and and it's just
such a funny character but he also did
that character on the Ben Stiller show
as a guy who taught exercise classes I
seen this so I think it's a valuable
character invoice and we had so much fun
and then the movie came out and Disney
didn't know what the hell it was you
have to remember it was a dizzy I watch
that now it's still like even I'm 33 and
it's still not only watchable in terms
of it being 2017 but in terms of me
being 33 I can just why and it's like
there's there it's not it doesn't feel
like I'm watching a weird kids movie
yeah it is it is a dark movie very dark
I couldn't Disney didn't know what they
were doing they were nailing their their
their live-action kids stuff and yeah it
was a strange time and we were lucky
enough to get to make it and then when
we showed it them they just looked at us
like what is this and it didn't do great
in the box office but oddly it's a lot
of people's a you know
favorite movie from their childhoods
yeah are you are you working on anything
right now that you're writing directing
because it seems like you're a little
bit more focused on finding kind of
great comedians and turning their lives
into movies yeah I was supposed to make
a movie this year and it fell apart
and now I don't know what the hell I'm
going to do but I've been having so much
fun working on love me Alec yeah yeah
and working Pete Holmes and crashing on
HBO and crashing is so fun last night we
were shooting at Ben's pizza next door
to the Comedy Cellar with the Lucas
brothers were they I love this band and
it's great to just have a little world
where you can invite all your friends to
act in it yes because it works you're
like hey there's Jim Norton let's check
him into it or hey Jeff Jeff Ross
happens to be walking by we'll throw
them in the scene and we're about to do
a big episode with Bill burr we're
excited about it's awesome and people
have really responded to the show and
Pete's so easy to work with he's so
funny and such a good writer that you
know we're really thrilled that we're
getting to do a second season it's a
really good show and I think what makes
it work and what's made a lot of your
movies about stand-up work is that you
are able to make things that are true to
stand-up it's not some weird
character of what people think stand up
might be like is already coming back
because that mean each part is coming
back coming back the great thing about
already on our show is already just
plays himself so matter what shape artis
in its appropriate to the show
we don't know art he's having a rough
week we're not going to use them we just
write it into the show yeah but Artie um
I guess had pneumonia and had to have a
procedure and he was at the cellar the
other night and I heard he was
hysterical look great and so we're about
to shoot a couple episodes that Artie do
you worry about Artie because like he is
so great on the show I always worry
about Artie we love him and he's
hysterical he is a brilliant actor and
he's also a very smart writer when we
improvise and talk about stories he's
got great ideas this is a ridiculously
talented person who's very sweet you
know when he gets in trouble he's he's
really only hurting himself
and so we all support him and root for
him to you know to stay healthy and
strong and and sober and you know he
definitely has a you know you know a
struggle we're all familiar with right
and you we want the best friend we'd do
anything for him so you've got love
which is based on somebody's story
you've got a crashing which is obviously
Pete Holmes you've got a the big thing
is Kumail you've got train wreck which
is Amy Schumer when you're doing
stand-up now I would imagine it's
impossible for you to get by without a
comic coming up to you and being like
you don't cha know I know if you've
heard my story but if you have a second
it doesn't happen that often honestly it
doesn't happen that often and very few
people have a story like this story in
the big sick that's it's a crazy true
life yeah that's really funny and
beautiful weird and as soon as I heard
it I thought that that's would make an
amazing movie but not I mean we will
have that good a story yeah yeah and
it's what's great about the big sake and
I think it's it you could say to string
around most of your comedies is that it
is like the kind of boy meets girl
rom-com but it's such a twist on the
story and even culturally like you're
not beat over the head with the fact
that this person comes from a different
culture but when I'm watching it
I realize like I'd not we've not heard
the perspective of somebody coming from
Pakistan before in America like not like
we're sitting here and like it's this
sort of sociological lesson but it's
just this dinner table conversation that
you're like I have not seen this before
in this way well I'm always interested
in just something I haven't seen yeah so
it's not like I thought I've got to make
a comedy with Muslims now or people from
Pakistan you what I think is no-one's
done something and it's fascinating and
let's do something that isn't hacky it's
just new training it's like doing a
movie with the you know with a lot of
hilarious women with bridesmaids right
it was like it's not like I thought oh
this would be great for women to do I
just thought here's it here's terrain
that has not been used up yeah and I'm
really proud of the movie and I'm proud
that it shows the perspective of people
from Pakistan and immigrants and Kumail
is so sweet and so funny and it yoomin
eise's people that I think are not given
that opportunity you know to show
themselves in their lives and their
perspectives so in that sense it's
become a little bit political but we
never made it for that reason we made it
it was a great story and it was just
interesting you know to hear about a guy
whose parents expected him to marry the
woman that they chose so you don't even
think that or what to call marriage is
happening in America like and it is
happening there arranged marriage like
you don't think you don't think arranged
marriages happen that's like something
from a villain in a Disney card exactly
it is happening it in probably 30 or 40
percent of the world is about arranged
marriages and so to me it's a comedic
situation yes how do you get out of
having to do an arranged marriage if you
fall in love with someone else and then
the cultural things are there but it's a
funny situation and it's also a unique
situation to be in a relationship with
someone who has to be put in a coma and
then you have to hang out with their
parents yeah and which could be funny or
the most unfunny thing in the world but
when it's Ray Romano and Holly Hunter it
becomes this incredible emotional
relationship that is also hysterical
because Ray
he's brilliant he's brilliant in the
movie and it's not like Ray Romano funny
that you're used to like he's not
playing Ray Romano he's yeah he's really
playing this role and he's funny in a
way that I don't think we've seen Ray
Romano do before which is what you want
out of a movie oh yeah I'm so excited I
was on the HBO young comedians special
with Ray Robottom I was going to ask you
what your connection is because I feel
like there have been Ray Romano
connections and references I start going
to Travis this morning I was like per se
like because that line in a four year
old virgin when he's like Everybody
Loves Raymond that's just a good show
yeah like that like sticks that have
stuck with me since the movies come out
and then and then you see them again in
funny people when I'm an emcee yelling
at them and you see and I'm like what is
it in Iraq which is a bull rode says
marriage is like an episode of Everybody
litter a bit but without the funny part
something like that
and I've always thought that Everybody
Loves Raymond was one of the greatest
shows ever on TV it is so funny and if
you if you're married or in relationship
so you really get how they nailed
everything and I was always blown away
by it and proud of Ray so it's over the
first few years I just referenced it as
a running joke then I would no matter
what reference Everybody Loves Raymond
and at some point when we were doing
funny people we asked him to be in it
and then that day
Eminem is there and we were improvising
with Eminem and then it just occurred to
us it would be funny if he just starts
getting really mad that Ray is looking
at him and he starts screaming at him
and what was funny was Eminem didn't
know who Ray was he literally had never
not only not seen the show I never heard
of the show really which I love because
what is he watching
what does Eminem watch all day that he
could miss seven year available Raven
except like not knowing what Seinfeld
ends that's like that Ray was like so
the joke here is that you guys don't
think I could defend myself and so when
we were casting the big sick I just had
an instinct from working with Ray on
finding people that he's just a killer
yeah and I had seen Holly Hunter when I
was on a college tour with my daughter
we went to Carnegie Mellon and we
visited an acting class and she was
there listening to kids do monologues
and then giving the
notes mm-hmm I watched her for three
hours help teach this class and so when
we're considering who to play these
parts I just thought I think the
universe wants it to be Holly Hunter
that's why I saw that and then we
thought is that a good couple does that
match up wow that is the weirdest
greatest idea but it made a couple it
makes the the friction that pops up like
even better yeah you know becomes
hysterical and and and they're not
getting along grade so yeah that's also
one of the interesting parts of the
movie is Rey and Holly Hunter are
married and the daughter gets sick but
they weren't getting along when this
happened so they also have detention of
their ongoing marital problems even
though they're in a hospital that's what
I love about your movies and it probably
says a lot about your personal life the
married couples never really get along
that well but um I want to I want to ask
you real quick you have to go on to your
next interview do you have like a are
you grateful
or are you bitter is it a chip on your
shoulder like what is your attitude when
you do something like crashing or
whatever you're doing it feels like your
attitude of getting people that you like
and funny people around you and just
doing stuff with them it's always been
that way now you're ridiculously
successful and most of what you do
becomes very successful you were doing
this before and like yet fans like me or
critics that like things like undeclared
and freaks and geeks but this was your
strategy back then and it would work for
a while it wasn't clicking like well I'm
glad it collected there was a moment I
remember I was walking around to Sony
lot and I bumped into Ben Stiller and
everything I had done had failed for a
while I'd been just went man you really
do for a hit and luckily I was able to
collaborate with Adam McCain Will
Ferrell an anchorman yes and I think
when that succeeded it really opened the
door for everything else for me because
when you don't have any hits people
question all your choices right what
would you why what would you know you
don't have any hit exactly as soon as
you have it people trust you and it has
a result of getting trust you could do
better work because people aren't
interfering in the same right and so
that changed changed everything so
I'm very excited that people are doing
good work and I'm just trying to find
people that are fun to collaborate with
like you know Paul rust on love and Pete
Holmes on on crashing and it's exciting
and I was nominated for an Emmy
yesterday congratulations for my white
good and strawberry and get to talk
about commentarii I got 30 for 30